[Music]
first up is a snack eaten by NBA fans on
a budget ladies and gentleman please
welcome the bag of generic brand cheese
puffs good job Annie
are you ready generic brand cheese puffs
and almost and I got an upskirt shot
there that I
did not want to sing all right get the
Huggies bowls yeah next up ladies and
gentlemen our next mascot is a comic
book hero who's already dressed for
Halloween it is ladies and gentlemen
Batman in a hamburger helper costume are
you ready
compromise Lord of Darkness go man go
and again we're just looking at his ass
that is not a happy looking Batman next
up the result of a cross sport promotion
it's the NFL's AFC Pro Bowl offensive
line guys you ready
[Applause]
all right we'll see you in five to ten
years guys thank you very much one of
them got a basket I don't know who
though it doesn't matter right yeah in
prison they're all the same and their
lawyers will figure it out here we go
next up I'm sorry I could watch that all
day
next up is a mascot who's been banned
from most NBA games it's a half-filled
canister of Purple Haze medical
marijuana
[Applause]
don't worry everybody he didn't feel a
thing
he's gonna be fine that's all kale by
the way in case you're watching our next
step it's the guy who smoked half a
canister of Purple Haze medical
marijuana let's see him do his best dude
[Applause]
[Music]
seems perfectly happy and he's a fan
yeah okay dude
our next mascot is what those NBA fans
down at the local fraternity live off of
it's the frat fridge that hasn't been
cleaned in nine months let's get it out
here the frat fridge that hasn't been
cleaned are you ready Fred fridge
[Applause]
I know Hey yeah great let's go get those
hard boiled eggs off the tram get those
frozen waffles out of the way of our
next mascot here's our last mascot it's
our old friend the masturbating bear let
me clarify the masturbating bear
undergoing a 21-day quarantine after
performing at a bachelor party in
Liberia
[Music]
[Applause]
Gobert go
very nice favorite
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Applause]
you